[Musique]
nous les femmes nous disposons tout d'un
super pouvoir
oui un super pouvoir qu'on découvre à
l'école primaire et qu'on a un peu trop
tendance à oublier
alors c'est quoi ce pouvoir
l'invisibilité oui madame vous aussi
vous avez ce pouvoir un super pouvoir
offert par une simple règle de grammaire
le masculin l'emportent sur le féminin
quand on applique cette règle même un
simple tabouret peut rendre les femmes
invisibles
oui on dit bien que 100 femmes et un
tabouret ont été pris en photo à croire
que les femmes et sont là pour mettre le
tabouret en valeur
ah oui c'est vrai c'est une
particularité de la langue française qui
pourrait prêter à sourire est un
monsieur s'est vu
personnellement
ça m'a pas fait sourire quand j'ai
entendu cette règle pour la première
fois
j'ai 8 ans je suis en ce2 une classe de
25 élèves 15 filles et garçons j'aime
apprendre comprendre découvrir tous les
possibles qui s'offrent à moi je suis
entourée de mes dix copains et de mes 14
copines on est au même niveau
je suis visible on est toutes visibles
plus que même
majorité oblige
le couple tombe et d'un coup nous avons
disparu au profit des garçons
nous n'existions plus je n'existais plus
dans la phrase vous non plus madan vous
non plus un visible et une seule
question sur mes lèvres
pourquoi
c'est vrai ça pourquoi je dire ça vous
choque pas vous pourquoi
parce que c'est la règle c'est comme ça
c'est vrai à quoi bon lutter à beyond ou
de transparence à quoi bon lutter contre
l'immobilité de la sacro-sainte de
langue française
elle a toujours été comme ça n'est ce
pas
et ben non
elle n'a pas toujours été comme ça parce
qu'en fait cette règle là qu'on grandit
elle a que quatre siècles
c'est en effet au xviie siècle que
fraîchement créé l'académie française
notamment va procéder minutieusement et
sans faux semblants à une véritable
masculinisation de la langue
par exemple cette très chère police de
la langue comme elle aime se nommait va
décréter que je cite le masculin
l'emportent sur le féminin au titre que
l'homme
est plus noble que la femme
rien que ça
le scandale provoqué à l'époque déjà ne
faut pas croire c'est quand même pas
passer crème
scandale il a pas empêché notre boys
club des grammairiens et leurs potes
académiciens de continuer ses réformes
et d'affirmer sans vergogne que les
féminins sont des dérivés des masculins
tels eve née de la côte d'adam
et puisque ça suffit pas
c'est quand même dommage avouez le de
s'arrêter en si bon chemin
arrivons supprimer progressivement tout
un tas de noms féminins
mais attention pas n'importe lesquels de
préférence des noms féminins qui se
rapporte à des fonctions prestigieuses
fonctions donc pas qui par définition
sont le propre des hommes seuls saleh
tous ces noms qui servent à rien
personne n'a jamais vu une femme écrire
franchement
adieu doyenne poétesse t'interesse
autrice
par contre une aigles devient un aigle
merci napoléon est un erreur devient une
erreur
à vous conviendrait que l'orientation et
biologiques derrière tout ça elle est
difficile à nier il est même très assumé
en gros on peut pas empêcher les femmes
de faire on peut pas empêcher les femmes
d'exister mais on peut les empêcher de
se nommer et ne pas nommer faire
disparaître le féminin de la langue
française c'est faire disparaître les
femmes de l'imaginaire populaire c'est
nous rendre invisible
je vous sans frémir
pourtant c'est pas du militantisme
exacerbée c'est un fait
quand on parle au masculin on pense à
quoi
ni madame on pense à des hommes et quand
on entend du masculin on comprend quoi
bravo vous suivez on comprend sommes
en fait dès lors qu'on parle de
personnes le cerveau humain est leur
attribue systématiquement un genre le
cerveau humain ne supporte pas
l'ambiguïté
le masculin ne peut tout simplement pas
être neutre puisqu'il est attribuée
systématiquement et spontanément à des
hommes c'est normal c'est le sens qu'on
a appris en premier et le cerveau il va
pas chercher à aller plus loin il va pas
gaspiller son énergie et s'arrête alan
poul qui s'éclaire en premier
tout ce que je vous dis là je n'ai pas
sorti de mon chapeau
fait je vous invite vraiment à lire les
ouvrages notamment des lianes viennot ou
encore vous intéresser aux travaux de
pascal gygax pour ne citer qu'elle est
lui
vraiment fait le ca vous éclairera on va
faire un petit test
si je vous parle d'un groupe de
chirurgien quelle est la première image
qui vous vient à l'esprit
c'est bien groupe d'hommes et maintenant
si je vous demande quelles sont vos
acteurs favoris qui allez vous me citer
en premier
on est d'accord que j'ai dix acteurs au
pluriel
du coup c'est un pluriel notre qu'inclut
le féminin et masculin
et pourtant vous avez très probablement
pensé d'abord à des noms d'hommes
les effets de cette omniprésence du
masculin sur une représentation mentale
ont fait l'objet de plusieurs recherches
par exemple en 2009 l'université de
genève a montré que les adolescentes se
sentait plus confiantes en leurs
capacités à réussir dans des professions
qui leur étaient présentées au féminin
et pas seulement au masculin
le fait est que nous limitons nos
pensées nos idées mais aussi nos
ambitions aux mots que nous utilisons
il faut prendre conscience que la
société influence le langage autant que
le langage influence la société
civile a refait la société influence le
langage autant que le langage influence
la société
la bonne nouvelle c'est que la langue
française est là rien de sexiste fait
les solutions existent déjà et elles
sont très simples
par exemple on pourrait réutiliser
l'accord de majorité qui était employé
avant xviie siècle
cet accord qui nous permet de dire que
100 femmes et un tabouret ou été prise
en photo c'est quand même beaucoup plus
logique
on pourrait aussi réemployer les ces
mines historique
attention je vous parle pas des
entrepreneurs eux et auto re avec le
remue et qu'on entend à voit à peine et
que personne n'entend non je vous parle
de ressusciter les autres hills et les
entrepreneuses
je sais
certaines personnes trouvent que ça
sonne bizarre que c'est moche
mais je vous rassure parce qu'en fait
ces connotations et étrangeté elles sont
le fruit de mentalité et ce qui est
génial avec les mentalités c'est
qu'elles peuvent évoluer
en fait un mot il a pas vocation à être
beau un mot il sert à nommer une réalité
dépeindre des possibles est éclairée
l'invisible
quand on les cherche on les voit les
femmes sont là lever la main
les femmes sont là est certainement
majorité
mais moi j'ai pas envie de chercher j'ai
pas envie d'avoir à demander je veux à
chaque phrase les entendre les voir dans
la grammaire comme dans la société je
veux que nous sortions de l'invisibilité
dans laquelle on nous a plongés je veux
que comme le masculin et le féminin puis
ce peuple et l'imaginaire populaire
en fait je veux du féminin partout
ostensible assumer pour illustrer tous
les possibles et en créer de nouveaux
parce que oui la langue elle a ce
pouvoir là est la langue elle nous
appartient à toutes et à tous
la vie à huit ans dans deux mois elle
rentre en ce2
le compte à rebours est lancé
dans quelques mois elle qui parle une
langue si spontanément inclusive elle
disparaîtra
comme aux filles
noyés dans la masse masculine
dans quelques mois la grammaire la
valeur à tout entière
moi sachant ce que je sais il faudrait
donc je dise à ma fille
ma série
si désolé
tu vaut moins qu'un meuble
tue et
transparentes
tu ne laisse aucune trace dans la phrase
comment pourrait-elle après ça encore
crois qu'elle a le pouvoir de marquer la
société sis au profit d'un tabouret elle
disparaît
comment pourrait-elle encore porter son
genre avec fierté
je refuse
je refuse de contribuer à faire perdurer
sa
et vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]